after five epic seasons the last kingdom
has finished its run on netflix but fret
not the story of utrid of bebenber is
far from over in this video i'll be
going over season five's climactic
finish what this means for the future of
the franchise and sorting out these
names because odin be damned it can get
confusing oh yeah if you like these
types of videos fulfill your destiny by
liking and subscribing every little bit
helps me out this is king edward one of
the few names i can actually pronounce
he was ruler of the anglo-saxons from
899-924
throughout the season he's had to deal
with invading icelanders under the
command of breida the death of his wife
afled and betrayal by his father-in-law
ethel helm of wiltshire it's all
culminated in a final battle at the
northumbrian fortress of bevinburg which
seems like fate since it was bevinburg
where the last kingdom story started way
back in season one king edward has
struggled with whether or not to invade
this fortress not only is his niece
ilfun held captive inside but attacking
would put him at war with king
constantine of the scots but if edward
were to be victorious here he could take
out the king of scotland the bulk of the
scottish king's men have yet to arrive
so if there's any chance to strike it's
now but in doing so it would risk
killing his niece this is where utrid
comes in he has waited five long seasons
to reclaim his home which currently
belongs to his cousin whitgard
elfrickson who took over its command by
killing his own father elfric in season
4. because of his insider knowledge of
the fortress he knows there's a secret
yet dangerous way within its walls a way
which only a few men at a time can
traverse considering it entails climbing
these steep cliffs if they can get in
and rescue elfwhen edward can lay siege
without jeopardizing the life of his
niece meanwhile ethel stan king edward's
son stalls for time outside the ramparts
for you historians out there you'll know
ethel stan will eventually become the
first king of england a dream envisioned
by edward's father alfred in previous
seasons in fact utrid will later
foreshadow this unifying king by
chastising edward telling him that he's
not that man but the man who can unify
this country must be a figure behind
which the people can stand together as
one
you have shown that you are not that man
the events culminating in this battle
can be attributed mainly to one man
ethel helm of wiltshire king edward's
father-in-law he's been secretly
scheming to get his grandson elf weird
on the throne as it would allow him to
hold more power and influence if there's
one event that really set up this battle
it's the death of his daughter and wife
to the king queen ailflade ethelhelm
ordered the assassination of alice known
amongst the saxons as the visionary for
her visions of saint cuthbert the
assassination was supposed to look as
though it were done by the danes who at
this point in time are under the command
of sigtrigar iverson this was an attempt
to start a war between the danes and
saxons if such a war were to occur king
edward would need ethelhelm's army and
vast riches in order to win that's why
ethel helm wants this war the king would
be indebted to him but what ethelham
doesn't know is that his daughter in
secret accompanied alice on her voyage
so when the assassins came and asked
which one of them was the visionary
queen aylefled sacrificed herself saying
it was her so ethel helm's plan
ultimately resulted in both the death of
his daughter and king edward waging war
on sigr believing them responsible for
the death of his wife it's only until
later on in the season that uthred
discovers ethelhelm's plan but by that
time ethel hummus fled to northumbria
with his grandson with an entirely new
plan in exchange for king constantine's
help in raising rebellion against king
edward ethel helm promises half the
prophets of the land of mercia through
the marriage of his grandniece elfwin
and if constantine puts ethelhelm's
grandson on the throne in wessex he
guarantees no incursions into scottish
lands so this is a win-win for both
parties king edward's greatest weakness
according to ethelhelm is his
impulsiveness and this is shown when
king edward decides to attack the
fortress even though utrid hasn't given
the signal that he's retrieved lady
elfwin and this impulsiveness works to
constantine's advantage in a stroke of
tactical genius constantine makes it
appear as though his men are fleeing
when in reality this is all a ruse to
get edward's men closer to the fortress
so that when the scottish reinforcements
arrive edward's army will be attacked
from two sides meanwhile utrid has
tasked the none healed with taking lady
ilfun to safety hild and utrid used to
be lovers and as we'll see later on in
the finale hild will later bring back to
bebenber in unexpected surprise but more
on that in a bit with the scottish
reinforcements arriving edward's men are
pushed towards the sea with many men
plummeting to their deaths among these
cornered men is ethelstant and kinlafe
the man lady elfwin really wants to
marry if help does not come soon all of
them will perish this is when utrid
rides off to engage the help of his
daughter stiora's danish warriors at the
end of season 4 stiora went off to start
a life with siegtriger and she had to
watch her own father execute him a few
episodes prior at the behest of king
edward don't worry it was sick tigger
who asked him to do it stiora believes
this fight to be over but utridge gives
an impassioned speech stating that if
they help he promises them peace in a
land where danes and saxons can live in
peace and just as it looks like king
edward's men are to be wiped out stiora
and the danes come to the rescue while
utrid makes his way into the heart of
bevinburg to claim what is his he tracks
down his betraying cousin wittgar and
kills him by throwing him over a railing
and having him impaled ethelhelm knowing
the battle is lost tells his grandson
they must flee but they're interrupted
by elfwild's half-brother ethel stan now
elf weird is ready to protect his
grandfather but he doesn't know that his
grandfather has been lying to him that
it was ethel helm who inadvertently
killed elf weird's mother and when he
learns the truth elf weird tells ethel
stan to do with his grandfather whatever
he sees fit ethel stan lets ethel helm
live saying that he must now face the
agony he caused but ethelhelm knows
whatever lays ahead of him cannot be
good and thus he kills himself with
utrid victorious and bebenber finally
his he makes his way to the courtyard to
see it burning everything he's fought
for his entire life is about to go up in
flames until a miracle happens it begins
to rain almost as if to say that the
gods are with him is this fate is this
destiny one of the major themes of the
last kingdom has been that of destiny i
mean utrid can't go an episode without
saying his trademark destiny is all but
this season calls destiny into question
as several of those closest to utrid
question his blind faith in it
destiny is cruel
all it seems to do is cause us sorrow
and pain
perhaps pain is our choice
no destinies stiora chastises her father
saying he only believes in destiny
because it acts as an excuse for all the
pain it has caused him and others you
have always spoken as though every
action is part of some plan
everything you have done has been
excused because it was not your choice
for five season utred has been the pawn
of others his fate seems out of his
hands and he feels helpless because of
it sometimes i think that my fate is too
wander and to never arrive but it's not
until the final moments of the series
that utrid takes fate into his own hands
defies the king and creates his own
destiny with edward recovering from the
battle utrid makes a deal with
constantine behind the king's back of
course this isn't revealed until edward
makes it official that utrid will be
lord of northumbria and that he and his
kin will be made its rulers for all
eternity edward even proclaims that he
has utread their lives and thus the
danes may live peacefully in these lands
and edward's kind of gung-ho to go off
and fight the scots and unify england
once and for all but utrid reveals the
deal he made with the king of scotland
utrid will be the lord of north umbria
acting as a buffer between the saxons
and scots sworn to neither side to
ensure the peace edward sees this as a
betrayal but as utrid pointed out
earlier he does not believe edward to be
a man capable of achieving this unity
but the king who has just praised utrid
in front of everyone and knows he is
indebted to him kinda has his hands tied
to do anything about this we see a bunch
of cheerful reunions as the saxons and
danes celebrate their victory but it's
here we can see where the future of the
franchise is headed with a few
unresolved storylines it's been
confirmed by netflix that this is the
last season but fear not a movie has
been confirmed that will continue from
the books this series is based off
confirmed in january of 2022 on the
official last kingdom twitter account is
the new movie seven kings must die which
has already started filming it's based
on the final three saxon stories novels
war of the wolf sword of kings and
warlord now i have not read the books so
there won't be any spoilers there but
there are some unresolved story threads
this finale leaves us with first hild
brings ozbert to bebenber to learn of
his origins now we know that ozbert is
actually utrid's son he had with gisela
and the last we saw of him was way back
in season three when he was just a baby
with ozbert being the only male left to
pass on utrid's bloodline remember
utrecht's first son had his manhood cut
off by breida this may prove an
interesting development in the future of
bebenber utrid also asks edith to stay
longer under the guise that she should
help the wounded but there's been
romantic chemistry brewing between them
for some time now it's been hinted they
may get together way back in episode 1
when edith comes to visit and they joke
that utrid's still not married ooch is
still the same
what he's not married either
it looks as though ilf weird is in
prison but with his grandfather dead who
knows if he'll play a role in what's to
come we also have the birth of edward's
new baby edmund with his current wife
yet gufu i have so much trouble
pronouncing her name but as we know it's
ethel stan who will take over his king
in 924 and then go on to take over all
of england but what does that mean for
utrecht how does he go from being this
peacekeeper holding the scots and saxons
from all-out war to helping ethelstan
conquer all of england well he never
said he was against this so-called
unification he just said he didn't see
edward as the suitable one to do it
again i haven't read the books but
considering utrade was pivotal in
raising ethelstan the two will likely be
on the same side when unifying the
country now the season ends with utrid
overlooking the shores of his newly
conquered kingdom as we see flashes both
good and bad of some of the most major
events he's experienced over this
journey these are the major moments that
have led him up to this point today and
i think it's fitting the last flashback
is of him getting baptized baptism
represents forgiveness and cleansing
from one's sin and can symbolize
regeneration and renewal it can also
mean a fresh start which is what it
seems to represent for utrid who has
said throughout the season he wishes to
settle down and with utrid finally lord
of bevenber this series comes to an end
but hopefully we'll have words soon when
the story continues with the seven kings
must die movie thanks for watching
everyone what did you think of the final
season of the last kingdom i want to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
remember to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at the story yt
until next time remember destiny assault